so we have three types of
fundamental networks. We have the multi-layer perceptron
multi-layer perceptrons are sufficient for
Tabular data, so if you have an Excel sheet with five six
seven columns.
And you want to do regression or classification? You can create an
MLP.
And it's very trivial to create an employee with libraries like pythorg
and tensorflow.
if you're going to be dealing with
sick
images especially images of
three color channels and you will use a convolutional neural network
again the word convolution has to do with
This Matrix operation in a convolutional network.
We have two types of matrices The Matrix
representing the picture.
And the Matrix which is the kernel which is
used to.
for lack of whatever words to
observe the super pixels of
the picture
I think we've seen this before.
I think I've shown your kernel but not we will look at it. And then
and one of the sessions where we will do
you will use CNN for image recognition and then there's a recurrent neural
network. Long story short.
You would use MLP. You have simple tabular data. Everything is
numerical.
CNN's if you have
You know.
Square matrices anything that needs to be put in scrimmage like
a picture or videos after all videos are sequence of
pictures.
And our events if you have sequential data.
for time series for
speech to text or text to speech for set table
analysis.
by the way, if any of you are interested in
predicting stock
Is what predicting stock prices it's very problematic because
something you really can't really can't do
but beside if you're interested in.
You know buying and selling stocks.
Well the price of a stock.
Is strongly influenced by public opinion?
And so there are some companies that use sentiment
analysis to see what people are saying about certain topic.
Like what was that stock game game
stop?
Game Stop, right
and people
What was the what they were using when they were on
Twitter?
opposite of Short Selling
opposite of shorting
longing right they were trying
to Long the game start by showing people were talking about
the old Nokia or all the you
know,
electronic
forms of entertainment and so they were making the making
the price go up. So as people's basically you
could you set them analysis to see you are people
sentiment positive about this topic.
The price is going up. Let's buy it.
If the if people are saying negative things, let's say
I don't know the CEO of this particular company said something
very terrible. Well something very racist or
sexist or whatever and the price is going to drop and so
you can use sentiment last to detect that and then start
shorting or start selling.
Exactly wrong.
So now of course.
Getting access to the data is another story.
Then a bunch of nurse
that are going to stop exactly yeah as as to retaliate.
It's very fascinating story. But yeah the point is this
without going to off topic here you if you have
if you want to process sequential data like anything
do with time.
Or words or sound bikes
you won't use RNs, but of course,
like I said, you can be can combine.
Like for one problem that I'm working on I'm using
a drnn.
Which is a combination of convolutional networks and
recurred recurring units because what I want to do is go from
pictures.
to
a sequence of characters
Basically, I think I talked about this. I want
to look at a mathematic a picture of an equation.
And converted to a later code
which is a sequence of characters.
Yeah, and thank you one for sharing the the background
of that GameStop scenario.
So yeah, we'll set them allows as you can see, you know, what people are talking about and then
react.
or preemptively
Okay.
Now there is stuff. This slides have to
do with the mathematical representation.
Here's an example of using a CNN for
pictures.
So for example you take this picture of
a cat this picture of the cat is colored. So
you have at least three color channels red green and blue.
and each
channel will be put into its own Matrix, which we call
a
two-dimensional convolutional
layer, it's called 2 of 0 because we have two dimensions
for each color Channel.
And it's called the convolution because we're going to convolve.
the kernel
with
each
color Channel
now I will show you convolution in a
separate session, but the idea is in this particular architecture
you will go from
the picture to a flat Factor
again a linear transformation
and this flat
vector
will correspond to the distribution
Again by the way, yes matrices
are very important for new Networks.
But at the end of the day, this is still machine learning statistical
learning. So distributions are very very important.